so named coach is a new app that allows
students and soon staff and faculty to
enter their pronouns and how to
pronounce their name in a centralized
place and with the integration with
canvas at the moment it turns up in the
photo roster which is useful right now
for faculty and students and soon we had
a meeting yesterday soon we're hoping
for students to be able to see each
other's pronunciations and pronouns so
hopefully by the fall that will be the
case and I just want to say that I
really want to thank some of the folks
who work on canvas for pursuing named
coach we looked into this four years ago
maybe and decided it would be great for
Yale will be a wonderful fit we could
not find anyone to pay for it so I tried
for a year and finally gave up and then
I was invited to a meeting this December
that had the title name coated and I'm
like wait what and so the Registrar's
Office has offered to pay for this so
I'm really excited that it is here
alright so the kind of classes I'm
talking about are either some in our
classes this semester I'm teaching to
some in our classes of 20 people it
would also work I've also taught a big
lecture class with discussion sections
for teaching fellows so the kinds of
classes where you actually really want
to learn students names learn their
pronouns and use those things in your
classrooms so I just created the drama
of the first day of a seminar class so
shopping period is not a seminar
teachers friend are those of you who
teach this know this and so on the very
same day that I am trying to pay
attention to how students pronounce
their name to pay attention to which
students use which pronouns I have this
little kind of sheet that I'm scribbling
all the stuff down on is also when it's
totally packed with shoppers there
aren't enough seat for people probably
half of these people are not going to
end up in the class there's no class
list yet that's why I love freshmen
seminars first-year seminars they have
class lists so exciting and I'm trying
to get all this information and I'm
usually missing it and there's only so
many classes into the semester that I
want to keep doing the same go around at
the beginning um so I have a couple poll
questions in here for you so here's a
question about which pronouns do you use
with some of the examples that you may
find among ourselves and also among
our students let's just take a second
and do that and this is actually it
occurred to me so I have never used this
pole function before I am NOT the kind
of teacher that is predisposed to
figuring out a way to use this function
but this is something that you could
actually do in a large lecture class at
the beginning just to acknowledge that
actually there are people in this class
who use pronouns other than she her hers
and he/him/his so that would be really
helpful there we go a way of doing it
but I just wanted to use it as an
acknowledgement of some different
pronouns if you want more information
about pronouns come find me afterwards I
have more information about that and I
need to use this to get out of here okay
um so why do pronouns matter and I know
that some of you already are aware of
this I think it shows basic respect for
students and some of you may know that
for first-year students the very
incoming undergraduates the first time
they meet with their group of students
they're living with and their first year
advisor who's an upper-class student
they go around and they share their
names and their pronouns and we have
gotten universally positive response to
that not only from students who may use
non-binary pronouns or some of the
pronoun varieties that you saw on that
slide but also because any student who
has a sort of hidden thing that they are
worried about people knowing so whether
it's a disability or a very difficult
family history that they feel like they
will be accepted because people are
accepting other people's pronouns so
it's it's really I'm a lovely thing that
is getting more and more accepted among
undergraduates I'm an among graduate
professional students I think it's a
little bit slower among staff and
faculty so that's something else I work
on in another hat um the stress of being
misgendered so I also direct the office
of LGBTQ resources and I was sitting
around with my students talking about a
different presentation I was making and
they were just saying that that is the
worst thing of there they are they're
there not only when they are misgendered
but when they gently correct and say I
use they/them their pronouns which is a
common example and pickly when the
faculty member or the TF pushes back and
says well that's not grammatical or well
what does that mean what are you like
push back and basically refuses to use
those pronouns they basically tune out
of that class right that they're not
will
to engage so it's really it's really
important also it lets everyone know
your efforts to be inclusive on a lot of
different levels all right so have you
ever been misgendered and again this
would be an interesting thing to ask
your class even if it's a big lecture
class all right so people have had the
experience of being misgendered I think
if you are in the group that said no
it's worth paying attention to the
experience of being misgendered and also
being misgendered when you identify as
cisgender is different than the
experience of being misgendered when you
identify as transgender or non-binary
but i am going to move on now alright so
what are some strategies to try to
respect the pronouns of students in your
classes um one is to actually learn the
pronouns and I'm going to show you in a
second how named coach helps you do that
I will admit however that that can be
challenging and particularly with the
students I work with and the students
who take my classes sometimes also their
pronouns will change in the middle of a
class so keeping track of them is a big
intellectual effort there's another way
of there are two other ways of doing it
um one is just to use gender-neutral
terms for everyone so refer to the
student member of the class so have ways
of referring to people that where you
don't use pronouns and that may seem
very awkward but actually once you
practice it it can be very very helpful
another thing that's important is to be
able to practice use they in the
singular which may be ill again a little
awkward for you if you haven't done it
much before but if you practice it a
little bit I promise it will get it will
get easier another possibility is to use
students names and you don't have to
worry about their pronouns but you need
to pronounce their names correctly and I
will admit that I am probably better at
anglo-saxon names and in other other
name sources but I'm really working on
it and I really love name coach alright
so how does name coach look so I am
actually using a roster that we made up
for me
how do I get out to the other thing okay
I need to just get out of this so this
is a made-up class for me because I
don't know if I should admit but right
when I was going to post my class to use
to show it somehow the name coach
information got disconnected briefly
from the photo roster but this is what a
photo roster looks like so when students
have the opportunity to offer a
pronunciation of their name and their
pronouns they can write any pronouns
they wish there are some suggested
pronouns but they can write any pronouns
that they wish and for the students it's
super easy it's something called the
student information system so it's right
next to their address their preferred
name a lot of basic documents that they
go into really easily
and they can enter this information and
so basically when students have entered
it you'll see it like this and if you
want to see how to pronounce somebody's
name you click on this okay and then you
also see their pronouns and so this is
what I use when I'm learning who my
students are and so it's a it's a great
way of doing it I will also confess at
the moment in my class of 20 I only have
two students who have entered
information one of the reasons was we
didn't get this up and going until about
the second week of the semester and also
there's one little glitch still that we
had a meeting yesterday that we're gonna
have worked out by the fall so and also
hopefully when staff and faculty start
using it it will hopefully be in the
fall as well it will become more popular
okay all right oh here are my more
strategy so as I mentioned using
gender-neutral language and then also on
people worried about making mistakes and
unintentionally misgendering someone and
one of the ways that you can help make
that be less feel less hostile is by
setting up the basic idea that you are
very inclusive around gender in your
classroom
so when you introduce yourself and I
should have done that at the beginning I
think it said she her hers up there um
typically when I choose myself I'll say
and I use she/her/hers at the beginning
of a class the students know that I am
open to that conversation
I have she/her/hers in my signature and
named coach will actually start
replacing signatures for staff and
faculty but I I won't go into that now
all right a one last poll question how
many transgender non-binary students um
that you are aware of in your classes
this past year
okay so you sounds like looks like a lot
of you do actually have transgender
non-binary students so this tool should
help you more more resources and I have
a little handout if you stop by my table
these are resources in the back my
pronouns that org has like a little
online class if you're not really used
to kind of the etiquette of pronoun
asking and using it has like about a 10
minute little class that you can take if
you're really kind of more curious about
what it means to be transgender
non-binary as an experience this TED
talk by Scott Turner Schofield called
ending gender if you google that you
will find it is this 15 minute talk I
use all the time of my presentations and
then if you have somebody who's pushing
back on I won't use they because it's
ungrammatical there's a New York Times
Magazine article home 2016 by Amanda
Hess kind of being directly addressing
that so I think my time is up right and
I will be over there if you have any
questions but thank you
[Applause]